we think of Lisa and I was there in
Memphis and I think of her and what it
would have meant to be here are you
carrying a little bit of her with you
tonight she's carrying a lot of her with
me tonight
earlier today was saying you've brought
him now to a new generation does that
like compute in your brain it does
because of because of the fans that I've
got
12 year old kids who told me that it
changed their life and they're playing
the guitar now or
um or it's just brought joy to a little
kid and you just kind of think
that's that's just such a privilege to
get to be a part of something that that
can affect somebody on a positive way
like that